[Music]
on this Friday night on the road again
the confusion as Canadians look to get
away for the first time in months it's
long weekend the road map about where
and where not to go breaking news
tonight
some Canadian soldiers on the front
lines of the Cova 19 crisis test
positive plus the federal government
extends its emergency wage subsidy to
give businesses extra time to bounce
back and mixed messages as provinces
debate making masks mandatory in public
people don't want to take public transit
for now because they're scared
global national with Donna freezin
tonight Robin Gill good evening and
thank you for joining us to travel or
not to travel that is the question many
people are asking tonight as we head
into the May long weekend with kovat 19
restrictions starting to ease there's
confusion in some provinces over how far
people should travel from home and
whether it's okay to go to summer homes
and cottages in Alberta for example the
chief medical health officer has given
people the green light to go to the
cottage if it's within the province but
mayors of some major resort towns like
Banff are urging people to stay away in
tonight's top story
Erik Sorensen looks at what the
provinces are saying and how tourist
towns are reacting ahead of this unusual
long weekend for many Canadians it's the
first chance to put winter and busy city
life in the rearview mirror and escape
to the tranquility of am a long weekend
by the lake but this year's different
the highways aren't clogged and
travelers are prepared to keep to
themselves
well stay maybe two nights and come home
we're gonna be very careful and social
isolate and brought all our own food of
cottage country hasn't been entirely
welcoming but the resistance to visitors
has eased up maybe there's more
contagion in Toronto than here but the
fact is this is a free country and I'm
I'm a resident and I'm seeing we live
with them all year long they want to
check on their seasonal properties of
which they may not have seen in the last
six months so as long as they're able to
do it safely and responsibly I'm we're
encouraging people to be able to do so
but as travelers flocked to the ferries
and other weekend travel spots in BC one
community is not putting out the welcome
mat we have done a great job here on the
Sunshine Coast the mayor of seashell
told Global's the West block they have
many vulnerable seniors to think about
the message out here in BC is to stay
home the provinces have various cautions
in BC it's avoid all non-essential
travel they're keeping it simple in
Ontario stay home in Quebec the
suggestion is to avoid travel between
regions while in Atlantic Canada the
basic messages stay within your own
province the most open region are the
three prairie provinces where they can
go to campgrounds and cottages what
Alberta calls
travel responsibly but there are some
restrictions in northern Saskatchewan
and northern Manitoba but so called
responsible travel leaves tourist towns
like banff and canmore Alberta worried
about big crowds descending on them I
always said you know the time will come
when we will start to welcome people
back it's perhaps a little early to be
taking that open-armed approach across
the country there are mixed feelings
about travel this weekend but a common
theme of safety first so no matter where
we are this long weekend going out
should only be an option if we can go
out smart so up in cottage country this
street vendor says everyone just needs
to keep their distance a little bit more
back in the city life will be more
tranquil anyway a Victoria Day weekend
like no other more Canadians just
staying home Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto just as businesses across the
country take their first small steps to
reopen the federal government is
extending the emergency wage subsidy
program the benefit which covers 75% of
workers wages up to eight hundred and
forty seven dollars per employee per
week is being extended until the end of
August Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
says the idea is to give employers more
room to get up and running slowly if
they have to but as Michael Couture
reports it doesn't cover every business
in need of financial support
the shop floor of this baseball bat
manufacturer is usually buzzing with
workers but instead there's just the one
bovid 19 forced all sports to call a
timeout and forced owner Arlene Anderson
to lay off most staff the workers still
here are being partially paid by the
government's wage subsidy program we're
still selling online direct to consumer
sales and of course our revenues have
gone down dramatically overall we were
down about 85 percent in April while
other businesses are preparing for
reopening Anderson is still on the
sidelines waiting for sports to restart
so she can stop depending on the
government as a relief pitcher we will
extend the Canada emergency wage subsidy
by another three months with the
extension will come changes to
eligibility requirements that used to
state companies could only qualify if it
lost 30 percent of revenue as a result
of the pandemic be modified to help
companies as they struggle to restart we
wouldn't want people who are getting
back their business going to feel like
they have to hold back on their growth
on their expansion on their rehiring in
order to be able to continue benefiting
from the wage subsidies welcomed move
says the Canadian Federation of
Independent businesses however they
still want governments to address rental
relief for small and medium sized
businesses the rent support is just not
getting to individual tenants that have
had months and months of unpaid rent and
are now starting to reopen their doors
with battles with landlords that has to
be fixed and that's key considering how
many companies are suffering financially
government numbers show more than a
hundred and twenty thousand companies
have applied for help as a result the
program is paying the wages of nearly
1.7 million Canadians since the payouts
began on May 7th the emergency wage
subsidy has doled out more than 3
billion dollars and those numbers may
only grow the kovat 19 crisis goes into
extra innings michael accretor global
news Ottawa those with underlying health
conditions are
worried about the Canada emergency
response benefit running out before it's
deemed safe for them to go back to work
Heather Eurex west talks to one man
undergoing cancer treatment about the
health and financial risks he faces
Derrick Bosh has battled cancer on and
off for 23 years I've been diagnosed
three times with Hodgkin's lymphoma in
that time twice in the last three years
originally when I was 14 years old he
was about a quarter of the way through
his latest course of treatment when
fears around kovat 19 began to ramp up
because he was working with the public
he asked to be laid off from his job
since then he's relied on the Canada
Emergency Response benefit to pay his
bills the problem is that benefit only
lasts 16 weeks June 6 will be the last
check so right now we're saving we're
living off of nothing right now so that
we can extend this through the summer in
this far into the years we can go Bosh
is far from alone Diabetes Canada issued
a letter to employers asking they make
accommodations for diabetic workers to
ensure they are safe but not all jobs
can be modified to eliminate risk if
you're dealing with health issues that
has is always stressful it's been extra
stressful with the pandemic and then if
you throw in financial concerns as well
that's a major major kind of
conflagration of really just terrible
events all happening at once there are
other programs available to Canadians
who can't work for medical reasons but
Bosh says he's never been able to
qualify it for medical AI the prime
minister says an extension to the CRB is
under consideration our focus throughout
this entire pandemic has been the safety
and security of Canadians we know that
some Canadians are more vulnerable to
covet 19 because of age because of
underlying health factors and every step
of the way we have focused on giving
them the support we need that they need
for Bosh what's needed is more time at
home so we can finish treatment in
isolation without having to worry how he
will pay his bills
Heather Eurex West Global News Calgary
there are some breaking news tonight
from the Canadian Armed Forces
officials say five soldiers have
contracted Kovan
tene after helping out in long-term care
facilities in Ontario and Quebec
according to the military for soldiers
tested positive in Quebec and one in
Ontario the military did not reveal
where exactly the soldiers contracted
the virus but we do know that military
personnel are deployed at 25 care homes
in Quebec and five homes in Ontario as
part of Operation laser the Prime
Minister was asked today what's being
done to help protect more soldiers from
getting infected
there are always risks in what they do
and they go into that knowingly and
willingly at the same time we need to
make sure that we are doing everything
we can to protect them so we will look
at the protocols in place and see if and
how they can be strengthened as well as
ensuring that cases of kovat 19 don't
spread throughout the Canadian Armed
Forces BC revealed its plans today for
reopening schools premier John Horgan
says an optional part-time return to
classrooms will start June 1st with
reduced class sizes full time studies
are expected to resume in September new
health and safety measures will be
required including spacing desks apart
regular cleaning of high contact
surfaces and staggered breaks families
that decide not to send their children
to school may continue learning from
home in Newfoundland and Labrador all
classrooms will remain closed for the
rest of the school year parents and
students are being encouraged to
continue at home and online learning the
province is now working on a
comprehensive plan to reopen in
September which will depend on the
pandemic situation at that time we're
getting a look at the dramatic impact
the pandemic has had on home sales in
Canada according to the Canadian Real
Estate Association last month home sales
fell by more than 56 percent that's the
lowest volume for April since 1984 and
in Canada's hottest real estate markets
sales fell by more than 66 percent in
the Greater Toronto Area and by more
than 57 percent in Greater Vancouver but
so far home prices are not plummeting
the average price of a home sold last
month was 488 thousand dollars in the US
retail sales drop
by record 16.4% in april according to
the US Department of Commerce clothing
stores took the biggest hit with sales
dropping more than 78 percent the retail
industry is the nation's second largest
private sector employer after health
care and it cut 2.1 million jobs in
April the battle between the US and
Chinese telecom giant Huawei has
intensified tonight the US Commerce
Department is restricting huawei's
ability to use American technology and
software to manufacture semiconductors
the change is a big blow to huawei the
world's largest producer of 5g equipment
Huawei relies on american-made machinery
and software design to make the chips
for its smartphones and tablets the US
government blacklisted Huawei a year ago
deeming it a national security risk the
CFO of that company is wanted in the
u.s. accused of violating sanctions but
mungyeong show remains in Vancouver
under house arrest while she waits for a
ruling on her extradition hearing her
arrest has two Canadian men caught in
the middle of this fight between China
and the United States tonight our
Mercedes Stevenson speaks to China's
ambassador about Michael spa for and
Michael khovrakh Mercedes what did song
play woo have to say about their
detention Robin I asked about her song
about the status of Michael SPAWAR
Michael Kovarik who've been in jail now
for over a year and a half the Canadian
Embassy has not had access to those two
men in the last four months which means
they haven't been able to verify whether
they are in fact safe or healthy i asked
ambassador song about their cases which
many people inside the Canadian
government has described to me as a
hostage taking there's nothing like
hostage taking you know those two
Canadians are actually suspected engage
in suspected crimes of endeavoring
Chinese national security so the content
and Chinese authorities are handling the
case according to law and I would like
to tell you they are in good physical
condition and their lawful rights
protected according to law but I would
like to take to take this opportunity to
point out the actual
the biggest issue in our bilateral
relationship is still Moomin girls case
so that's why we have made our position
very clear to make sure that she's back
in China smoothly and safely so Robin an
interesting link made there between mung
Wong Jo and the to Michael's which the
Chinese government has previously said
there's no link between the Canadian
Embassy has asked for access via video
call or phone call to the to Michael's
given the covert 19 restrictions but so
far the Chinese government has refused
there's been a lot of criticism that
China mishandled the kovin 19 crisis
that it didn't reveal how bad it really
was
how did song respond to those
allegations well Robin the Chinese
government has a very different view of
how they've conducted themselves which
might come as a surprise to some
Canadians the Ambassador denies that
China has bullied countries who have
spoken out about China's handling of the
pandemic watch this rather China is a
victim not only of the disease itself
but also a victim of the information so
he's so you can see some politicians in
the United States they are raging
political campaign against China try to
smear Chinese image and that will help
in their fight against disease and to
save the lives of the American people
Robin we'll have more on the show about
where the virus came from in Wuhan what
else China is doing and the presence of
the Chinese government here in Canada
and whether or not they are trying to
intimidate Chinese Canadians and that's
coming up on the West block on Sunday
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa to mask or
not to mask coming up the mixed messages
about making masks mandatory in public
kovat 19 has had the biggest impact in
Quebec there are more than 41,000
confirmed cases in that province and
that number is more than half the cases
in the entire country
Quebec also has the most deaths more
than 3400 lives have been lost to this
virus today Quebec Premier repeated his
call for Quebecers to wear masks when
they leave home the government is
donating 1 million masks to hard-hit
Montreal there are calls in that city to
make wearing them mandatory as Mike
Armstrong explains there is no order on
the books yet but there are signs it's
coming for two days the city of Montreal
is handing out masks for free
the mayor says wearing a face covering
in public is the responsible thing to do
but she's reluctant to make it mandatory
I don't want our city to become a place
where you know there's a police officer
at every corner we don't even have the
capacity for this there is a growing
number of countries where masks are now
required in public according to an
international advocacy group masks for
all there are 94 countries with rules on
the books and some parts of Germany
fines run close to 400 dollars Canadian
in the u.s. parts of 38 states now have
some form of face covering rule Los
Angeles is one of the latest anyone
outside and around others has to wear a
mask although not everyone's getting the
message I was a little disappointed
honestly I don't see many people wearing
masks on the beach now in Canada
governments haven't ordered the use of
masks but some private companies have
several grocery chains now don't allow
shoppers unless their faces are covered
and as of Monday all uber passengers and
drivers will have to wear masks but in
Montreal the reluctance continues
despite increasing calls to make masks
mandatory we're the fifth worst hit city
in the world and we're still dragging
our feet on this it's inexcusable we
have to put everything on our side this
Montreal epidemiologist says
hand-washing and physical distancing are
important but
excuse me you niversary and obligatory
he says mask laws around the world have
been shown to have helped from my
perspective we're asking questions but
should not be asked kovat is clearly a
serious emergency human rights lawyer
Julius grace is a temporary mask law
would be allowed under the Canadian
Charter as long as masks are easily
available to everyone
one precedent gray says is smoking the
courts have found a smoker's right to
smoke can be limited when it affects
people around them like arms from Global
News Montreal still ahead the new fears
facing Roe hanger refugees in Bangladesh
Slovenia has become the first country in
Europe to declare an end to its copa 19
crisis slovenia's government says spread
is under control the Ministry of Health
reported one new case of the new corona
virus on Thursday with no deaths
reported but there are still bans on
public gatherings and people will still
have to wear face coverings in public
spaces European Union residents from
Austria Italy and Hungary are now being
allowed to enter Slovenia in Bangladesh
it's the moment aid groups have been
dreading kovat 19 has now reached the
world's largest refugee camp at least
two people have tested positive and are
now quarantined in the district of Cox's
Bazar it is home to roughly 1 million
Rohingya refugees who live in densely
crowded shacks access to health care is
limited there are fears a humanitarian
disaster will unfold if the virus
spreads unchecked what our kovin 19 toes
can mosquitoes spread the virus up next
york ovid 19 questions
the Victoria Day holiday weekend is an
occasion many Canadians spent outdoors
visiting family and friends but in a
pandemic different rules apply so what
will it look like under these
extraordinary circumstances our Jeff
sample took your long weekend specific
questions straight to the experts Jeff
the upcoming long weekend in May is
considered the unofficial kickoff to
summer and some are wondering whether it
will be safe to make to use the pool at
different times to swim with your
children coronavirus will subsist in
water and it will do so possibly for a
few days but it's highly unlikely the
diluted dose would be enough to make you
sick and chlorine should kill it within
about 15 minutes but if you do decide to
stick a toe in the water this weekend
keep an eye out for another covin 19
symptom Stephanie asks could you please
elaborate on kovat toes a small number
of patients reported reddish and purple
sores on the tips and tops of their feet
and fingers we don't entirely know why
it happens maybe it's related to little
tiny blockages and of blood vessels and
the tiny little blood vessels in your
toes and fingers yes I think it's
appropriate to meet people in the open
air if you're separated by the
appropriate two meters the virus is much
more likely to spread
indoors mostly because of ventilation
outdoors is always going to be safer
there's not shared air in the same way
my question is that I'm wondering if
after being in self-isolation
for more than eight weeks now if using
all these cleaning and sanitizing
products if there should be a concern of
developing a degraded immunity or
resistance to common day illnesses and
the answer is no and the reason for that
is it takes years of sterile exposure to
be new jeremy assistants ability to
recognize and insult a pathogen and rest
assured you're still being exposed to
plenty of nasty bacteria at home and one
more common question from canadians
hoping to step outside this long weekend
the answer to this one is no kovat 19
cannot spread through mosquitoes Jeff
sample Global News Toronto and that is
global national for this Friday I'm
Robin Gill we leave you tonight with a
long weekend challenge that's easier
than pie in this debut episode of
cooking with Doug Ontario's premier
reveals his self-proclaimed famous
recipe for cherry cheesecake from Rossum
prima open up the Cheesecake Factory at
a briefing this week Ford bragged he
made the best version ever now he wants
you to try thanks for watching and
remember stay safe stay healthy and
these are some of the fun things you can
do when you're self isolating
[Music]